this vast landscape is just part of what
many call
malwapu the land of the indigenous
mapuche
a rich fertile region stretching south
of the biobio river for 400 kilometers
today it's part of chile but as these
mapuche flags indicate
some of the land is being reclaimed
increasingly by force
in the last four months there have been
nearly daily arson attacks on trains
trucks and forestry companies that now
own the lion's share of the land
but also against farms and homes owned
by ordinary chileans
and people on both sides of the conflict
are being killed
outside of the jail in angol mapucha
community leaders announced
they'll fight by any means necessary for
the release of those they call
political prisoners of chile accused of
carrying out
attacks we are being persecuted and
imprisoned for demanding our land
for many years we were repressed but now
we've learned to organise and defend
ourselves
spokesman says new deployments of
chilean special forces units to the
region
are escalating the confrontation it's
getting dark here and
we're going we're starting to see now
military trucks
passing by this is what the local media
calls
the gaza strip and we're also seeing
here trees that have been chopped down
to try to block the road
so the cars can't pass and it will get
worse as
the night goes on as it becomes darker
because it's part of an ongoing campaign
of sabotage on the part of those who say
that they have to expel
the people who have usurped their land
for hundreds of years
neither the spaniards nor the subsequent
chilean state
was able to conquer the combat of
mapuche but by 1880
chile's army succeeded in driving them
off most of their land
destroying their rural economy and
plunging them into deep poverty that
persist
to this day
[Music]
now many communities are trying to take
back what they lost
like this property owned by chile's
largest forestry company
but they say it's also about countering
140 years of humiliation
today they've gathered for a game of
palin an ancestral sport played between
two communities in order to reinforce
their ethnic
and cultural bonds thirty-two-year-old
susanna soto says that like many
mapuches
her grandparents took up spanish names
to try to offset
deep racism and discrimination by
chileans
some of us may not have mapuche names
anymore but we still have mapuche blood
and we aren't ashamed of it we are from
a new generation that has the strength
to rise up again
[Music]
more than 12 percent of chileans
identify as mapuche
yet chile's constitution does not
recognize their existence as indigenous
people
supermarket owner delfin size says he
too belongs here
he takes us to see the remains of his
family's country home
just hours after it was burnt to the
ground by unidentified armed men
i feel nostalgia anger knowing they
burned down something that belonged to
us nearly 100 years
we can't rebuild our memories but i'm
going to rebuild the house
right here because no one can throw us
off our land
those resorting to violence are a
minority
but miguel angel says they're part of a
larger ancestral conflict that the
chilean state is refusing to address
except with force that's a military
plane with state-of-the-art technology
to intercept
telephone and radio signals it overflies
day and night when you see things like
this who can deny that this territory is
being militarized
impossible what's also become obvious
is that there's no easy solution to a
complex dispute
to which most chileans were oblivious
until now
that it's become impossible to ignore
lucia newman al jazeera
peleca chile